our MGM rebelling against Amazon and
their plan to create a Stargate movie
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so as you know over the last two years
I've been able to build up some really
nice connections between a few people
that work at MGM mainly thanks to
Amazon's purchase of MGM and how a lot
of people that work there are not happy
with it so they talk to me now actually
on Friday night or Saturday morning
depending now you want to see it I got a
phone call from one of those sources I
woke me up I was not very happy I
basically told them that somebody better
be dead or I was going to be really
really unhappy and then the store
started talking to me and I actually my
instinct was oh no they've been caught
they know they've been talking to me
they've been sacked oh no but then they
told me went on to tell me no no
everything's fine don't worry
but I do have some interesting
information to tell you as it turned out
they've had a few drinks and they've
forgotten about the time difference here
in the UK of eight hours
but I forgive them now if you are a
regular site tracker you'll know that a
couple of weeks ago I dropped the
bombshell the Jennifer salkey the head
of Amazon and MGM Studios has dictated
to the new head of film for MGM and
Amazon Studios
um Courtney Courtney Valentini
to create a Stargate movie She Wrote
This directive which basically gave her
permission to begin the development work
as well as the development work on
several other projects that have paused
while MGM was waiting and looking for a
new head of film
so we all got very excited but we knew
again if you're a regular side tracker
that actually Jennifer saki's voice was
kind of Lone in this wanting a movie
that everybody around her Michael Wright
for example who actually is head of MGM
plus wanted a TV series apparently Mark
Fergus who is the head of penguin and
Parker who will be hopefully show
running this project wanted a series
she was really the only one that was
saying let's do a movie a cinematic
movie at that now the reason for that
was because Amazon has given them a
bunch of money to make five or six
cinematic releases a year and she thinks
that one of those should be Stargate now
I don't have a major problem with that
my only real disappointment is that a
cinematic released movie will take a lot
longer to get to our screens than just a
television series a TV series could be
on a screens within six to nine months a
lot of the development Works already
been done so it would just really be a
matter of getting into a studio a movie
we'd be looking at two years and then
hopefully that would kick-start a
franchise and a series might follow it
quite quickly
but there is a risk of that that if the
Cinematic release bombs
it could kill the franchise before it
even gets to begin so we're a little
nervous but the thing is this is not
what the fans want now I put a survey on
our community page and I said what do
you want guys do you want a movie or do
you want a series 82 percent of you said
a TV series only 18 want that cinematic
movie now what I'm being told from my
sources at MGM is that actually MGM have
done an internal survey of their own
that they spoke to a couple of thousand
customers and they ask them what do you
want do you want a TV series or a movie
apparently the results of that survey
was kind of the same as ours roughly 80
of them came back and said we want a
serious this has triggered a bit of a
Revolt Michael Wright and others
Executives within NGM and even
apparently Amazon are now questioning
whether the movie is a good idea and
they've gone back to Jennifer salkey and
said shouldn't we be doing a series it's
lower risk we've already done loaded the
development work and it's what the fans
want because at the end of the day a
two-hour movie would be great
but a 10 hour series would be greater we
would get to see far more character
development we'd get to see far more
development of a story we'd get more
Stargate which is at the end of the day
what we want then we have absolutely no
Insight in whether Jennifer saoki would
change her mind I don't know a great
deal about Jennifer saki other than what
I've seen in projects she's done in the
past but I am told she is quite a
determined lady and at the end of the
day you don't get head of MGM and Amazon
Studios without being
determined
so would she be the type of person that
would push forwards with a project like
this even though the rest of the team
was saying it was a bad idea
there is however a risk that comes with
this
I have seen and we have all seen in the
past projects like this get canceled
because the team doesn't agree there's
infighting and when that starts
happening it derails projects really
quickly this has happened a lot with the
DC really what happened to the Justice
League was because of an unfortunate
tragedy with Snyder yes
but then somebody else came in there was
a lot of infighting there was a lot of
problems and it just basically created a
bad product at the end I don't think
it's just a danger though potentially of
there being a bad product if the team
the management team Etc aren't really on
board with the movie I actually think
it's in danger of just becoming canceled
altogether Jennifer sarki might just get
to the point of going this isn't worth
the trouble actually if we can't get on
board let's just not do it and cancel
the Stargate return all together now
I've not been told that by any sources
it's just a worry that I've developed
over time this story has been such a
bloody roller coaster of if buts and
maybes and near misses that I'm really
starting to get a little dubious about
the possibility that it could return
because every time we get a big yes and
a big excited plan seems to be
developing it seems to be two steps
forwards and three steps back I think
now we've got lots of people like Jenny
stiven and even Joseph malozi coming out
and publicly saying that Amazon are 100
definitely developing something with
Stargate but we don't know what that
something is and also the problem is
Amazon and MGM can change their minds a
lot and have done and that's not just
Amazon and MGM by the way that's all of
these big production companies thing is
we don't normally get to see behind the
curtain like we have done with the
Stargate project thanks to the sources
I've been speaking to normally we only
get to see the end result we don't get
to see all the arguing and the mind
changing and the panicked decision
making that seems to go on
we only ever get to see the result
so maybe this is perfectly normal and
that we shouldn't be concerned
or maybe the Stargate project is just
bloody doomed but I would say that
anything worth doing is worth doing
right and this would be the greatest day
of my life other than when my kids are
born and maybe when I got married
when Stargate returns so it's worth the
wait it's worth the conversation and we
have to keep talking about it because we
want Stargate to return
but guys get into the comments and tell
me what you're thinking is this just one
more kick in the teeth we're really
starting to lose Faith now or is this
just how business works and we shouldn't
really worry about it too much and
actually could it be a good thing in the
end if the doubters are able to persuade
Jennifer saki that actually a series is
the way to go because at the end of the
day it's what we want get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you're
thinking if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps out and
you'll never miss any of our new shows
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where for a small
contribution each month you can see most
of our videos first and without the
adverts you also get a Mogan a t-shirt
or whatever depending on which level you
buy so always good also check the
description there's lots of links to
lots of lovely Side Track related things
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign foreign
[Music]